hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today
we're going to have another solo podcast
that is to say an episode of mindscape
with only me talking I think that when I
started mindscape which was very close
to one year ago where I think we're
close to the anniversary I'm not sure
what it is but I had in mind I'd be
doing more than once every year
solo episodes but the truth is I've just
had too many interesting people to talk
to so I've had wonderful guests coming
to my horizon and it's been a lot of fun
talking to them so there's no regrets
there but I do want to mix in some more
solo episodes so I made an effort to
record this one the last one of course
was a very different one in the sense
that I had written a paper on why is
there something rather than nothing for
a scholarly collection of essays and I
could basically go through the arguments
in that paper and explain them so it was
kind of figured out already it was it
was a completed sensible work today I
both want to be a little bit more
controversial but also be a bit more
conversational that is to say talk about
something where I don't have a complete
polished argument so it's more of a
conversational off-the-cuff ruminating
about things trying to get some thoughts
into people's minds including my own
so thinking out loud as it were but I
will be a little bit controversial so I
want to talk about what it means to be a
good person or in slightly more formal
language how should we think about
morality and ethics what is right what
is wrong in particular I'm a naturalist
I don't believe in God or the
supernatural so how should natural ists
think about morality of course I did
organize a whole workshop a few years
ago on moving naturalism forward got a
bunch of people together so rather than
the idea there was rather than argue
about God not existing which we all
agreed on by the construction of who was
in the room we start with God not
existing we ask ourselves okay what next
you know there's various things that
happen when you're religious various
roles that are played by religion in
one's lives how do we replace them there
are a lot of issues facing natural ists
how to find meaningfulness in your
life the issues of freewill and
consciousness and other programs within
science that are not yet complete but
clearly one of the big issues is
morality how do you be a good person
what sets the standards for right and
wrong this is something about which
natural ists disagree and I think it's
good the natural ists disagree in the
sense that we are looking for the right
answer and we haven't yet found it or at
least some of us might have found it
it's like the interpretation of quantum
mechanics some of us might know the
right answers but we don't agree amongst
ourselves so there's more discussing to
be done as I am discussing this as I'm
talking to you right now recording this
podcast we've just had a wave of laws
being passed in multiple states in the
United States dramatically restricting
access to abortion or criminalizing
abortion abortion is of course a classic
moral dilemma kind of problem people
come down on different sides of it for
very different reasons I think a lot of
people you know I think I agree with the
argument that says that a lot of people
who oppose abortion rights oppose a
woman's white right to choose do so
because they like restricting women's
choices because it's just simply a tool
of oppressing women and expressing their
individuality and agency but not
everyone we oppose is abortion for those
reasons I certainly know people who
simply in good faith because of their
religious beliefs think that abortion is
wrong they think that there's something
that happens when an egg is fertilized
by a sperm and that's when you become a
person and that person deserves rights
this is again not necessarily the
political reason why abortion is a
controversy but it is something that an
argument you can make what should
natural ists
think about this if you don't think that
there's anything mystical or
supernatural or religious or spiritual
that happens at the moment of conception
then you have a whole different set of
issues in front of you and concerning
whether or not abortion should be legal
on the other hand I do think that most
natural ists have the same answer to
that question that's not a hard question
for natural ists
a single cell even if that cells a
fertilized egg
most naturalist would not attribute met
many rights to write so most natural
ists are going to say that women should
be able to get abortions at least for a
certain period of their pregnancies so
what about the hard problems there
plenty of hard problems the death
penalty what we should do is end-of-life
how we should distribute money in
society what is fair and so forth
trolley problems are famous moral
dilemmas that we can wrestle with so I
want to talk about a couple of things
that are a little bit more or a little
bit less obvious I should say for the
naturalist I want to give my general
feelings about them which are admittedly
themselves provisional you know I'm not
trying to talk about things for which I
think I know the right answer and rather
than simply focus on broad principles
and abstract reasoning I want to bring
things down to earth with a couple of
examples that people have strong
feelings about so I picked two examples
one example is vegetarianism is it
ethically okay to eat meat to eat
animals and animal products this is
something that has come up both
occasionally on the podcast and also on
my ask me anything special podcasts on
patreon if you're a patreon supporter
you know that every month I do and ask
me anything when all supporters can ask
questions and I try to answer as many of
them as I can see how I cleverly worked
the existence of the patreon in there if
you want to go to patreon.com/scishow
mmm Carol or just go to the podcast web
page you can find the link and be a
patron patron yeah be a patron yourself
so okay I mean I'm not a vegetarian but
I understand I think why some people
would become a vegetarian I think it's a
very very good example of a moral
dilemma facing naturalist it's not
obvious whether we should eat meat or
not so I will talk about that and then
the second issue I'm going to talk about
is exemplified by the intellectual dark
web this is something that you might
have heard about it's a group of people
sam harris jordan peterson ben shapiro
other people many of them are bloggers
and podcasters and they have a certain
take on things that i don't really agree
with i'm not sort of an intellectual
dark web sympathizer in some ways i am
and so you know when i started the
podcast people were asking me
I was becoming a member of the
intellectual dark web not many people
not people who knew me very well the
particular thing that they talked a lot
about in the intellectual dark web are
issues of social justice racism sexism
and so forth with the angle that the
people who are social justice warriors
the people who are spending a lot of
their time arguing that there's too much
racism and sexism and transphobia and
homophobia in our culture we need to do
something about that have gone too far
and in particular they've gone too far
in squelching debate and being counter
to the Enlightenment values of open
discussion and free speech so I want to
talk about that and explain why I am NOT
very sympathetic with their overall
attitude so hopefully between having a
whole bunch of committed vegetarians
disagree with me and a whole bunch of
intellectual darkweb supporters disagree
with me I will have annoyed or pissed
off a large swath of the listenership
here that's the goal or at least to get
people thinking I hope that I'm
thoughtful enough and open-minded enough
that even if you're a little bit annoyed
I try to give us some interesting things
to think about like I said my particular
ideas here are not completely settled
but it's important that we have these
conversations especially about difficult
topics especially about things with
which we disagree with each other so
let's go
[Music]
before examining these examples in any
detail I wanted to say a little bit
about how I personally think about
morality again I'm not a moral
philosopher myself I'm not an expert in
these things I've read a little bit I've
talked to people I care about the issues
but I'm not gonna be giving you the
complete expert opinion on the entire
landscape of moral and ethical theory
I'm going to talk about how I think
about it and invite you to think about
it yourself chime in in the comment
sections in various places on the
internet etc roughly speaking when we
think about morality or ethics the rules
by which we live there's two kinds of
questions we have to talk about one is
ethics itself the rules or the
guidelines for how we behave how we
should behave and then there's meta
ethics how we derive and justify what
those rules are so if you have a rule
well you should aim for the greatest
good for the greatest number that's part
of ethics or morality but where did that
come from
why should we actually aim for the
greatest good for the greatest number
that's part of meta ethics and to make
things way oversimplified in ethics I
find it always useful to distinguish
between two different approaches to
ethics or morality I'm not gonna
distinguish as an expert would between
ethics and morality sorry about that
there's many different approaches to
ethics morality but two particular
examples do a very good job of
illustrating kind of the space of
possibilities there's a ontology and
there's consequentialism de ontology is
saying that morals come from a set of
rules and if you write down the rules
and you obey them then you'll be in good
shape
whereas consequentialist think it's not
about this is what you should do or you
should not do what matters is what the
consequences of your actions are
unsurprisingly so utilitarian who thinks
that you look for the greatest good for
the greatest number that there's some
number called utility that you can
attach to different things that could
happen in the world and what you want to
do is add up that number and maximize it
that would be a typical consequentialist
where as a Content
for example a money well can't suggested
the categorical imperative where he says
that you should make your own individual
actions such that they could be
generalized to universal principles
that's a more de ontological approach
both of these approaches in my view have
serious problems with them they lead us
into sticky situations they ontology
runs into the problem that well it's the
same problem that every bureaucracy runs
into right when you have a bureaucracy
it's typically well-meaning you want to
do something like have rules for how we
drive our cars on the road but the
problem is you have to imagine that you
can figure out ahead of time what every
situation is in which those rules are
eventually going to be applied and
eventually you come up with situations
where there's an obvious right thing to
do and the rules are telling you
something different a classic example
for kontin's is the idea of lying I'm
not even sure what contem self believed
about this because I think there is
controversy and I'm not an expert but
there's the idea that you should never
lie because if you were obeying the
categorical imperative then lying is not
something you want to be generalized to
an action that everyone should take but
what if you're hiding a refugee in your
house and a murderer wants to come and
murder them right should you tell the
murderer that the person hiding from
them is in the basement or should you
lie and say something else so it's easy
or not may be easy but at least very
often possible to come up with apparent
counter examples to the day ontological
rules that people generally suggest when
it comes to consequentialism of course
it depends on your version of
consequentialism utilitarianism again is
the is a standard example so the idea
that you have something called utility
some number that judges or characterizes
measures how good two things are going
and we can somehow add up that number
and that's the thing we should try to
increase or to maximize I think sounds
very intuitively compelling or plausible
but it just doesn't hang together once
you actually put it to work in the real
world there's one famous example of a
inclusion which you might not like that
comes from utilitarianism in fact it's
called the repugnant conclusion by
philosopher Derek Parfit and roughly
speaking it says if you think that most
or any or all human lives have positive
value that just to exist gives some
positive utility or whatever it is
you're trying to maximize then very
quickly you come to the conclusion that
the morally right thing to do is just
increase the number of people no matter
what else right you can always do better
by having more people around you could
maximize the population of the world
which sounds like not necessarily the
actually right thing to do when I'm
writing my recent quantum mechanics book
something deeply hidden I sit his puzzle
in the light of the many-worlds
interpretation I said if you were naive
utilitarian trying to think about many
worlds you would say look every time I
branch the wave function of the universe
into two worlds if I think that the
amount of utility in each world is
positive then it's clearly a moral good
to bring new worlds into existence since
I am increasing utility so I invented a
machine called Q mad Q um ad which
stands for quantum utility maximizing
device and the quantum utility
maximizing device Q Matt basically just
takes a spin and bounces it back and
forth as fast as possible measuring its
value of spin up or down across
perpendicular directions and every time
that happens the wave function of the
universe branches into so you create
many more people they all had positive
utility or at least in aggregate they
have positive utility so you are the
best person in the world in terms of how
much extra utility you're creating even
though literally no one in the world
knows that you're doing anything and
you've had no effect on the lives of
anybody that sounds wrong right that
violates our intuition now in the case
of many worlds there's a simple fix for
that just like energy conservation you
can say that in fact the utility that
you add up should be multiplied by the
wave function squared by the amplitude
of that branch of the wave function
squared so then when you divide the
universe in two even though there are
now two universes
the total utility doesn't change at all
but more generally it's that kind of
thing that gets you in trouble with
utilitarianism our moral intuitions
don't necessarily fit easily with the
idea that there is a number that we
should maximize out there which we call
the utility now you might say you know
who cares why do i why should I care
about that what difference does it make
if my moral intuitions come into
conflict with some systematic version of
what is right and what is wrong if I
have a moral system if I figured out in
my mind the once and for all correct
rules of ethics and morality than the
fact that my intuitions or natural
impulses go into conflict with that
should be completely irrelevant my
intuitions might be wrong the system is
right right that's a little bit of a
sticky situation though I think the
origin of coming up with the idea that
we should maximize utility or that we
should act in a way that other people
should act and so forth all of these
eventually come form our moral
intuitions we don't pick these things
randomly that there is some place that
they originate from and I think that our
moral intuitions are it so let's think
about that a little bit more carefully
that means moving to the meta ethical
question right why are we justifying
these rules in the first place and again
there's an enormous amount of
categorization and specific theories in
this field that I'm not going to go into
but we can contrast very roughly realism
versus anti realism in morality right
and that basically gives the definitions
you might expect a moral realist thinks
that moral claims like this action is
good or this action is bad are real real
in the same sense that tables and chairs
and atoms and the expansion of the
universe are all real they're
objectively they're roughly speaking
whereas an anti realist either might not
believe in morality at all or believe
that there is morality but somehow it's
subjective that morality is a human
construct that could be different could
either could have been different for
different societies or could literally
be different for different people in the
same society so this is a very good
question a very deep question and one
that is nowhere near resolved as far as
I can tell within the philosophical
community I think that according to a
famous survey of different philosophers
and their opinions about different
knotty philosophical issues the
philpapers
survey most philosophers are moral
realists they think that there really
are moral rules that objectively exist
in some sense I personally am NOT at the
very very least I would strongly claim
that whatever moral strictures are
whatever moral guidelines are moral
rules whatever they don't exist they
don't have reality in the same sense
that tables and chairs have reality
maybe that there's some different sense
of reality that they have I would be at
least willing to contemplate that
possibility but they don't have reality
in the same way they're not part the
physical universe in precisely the same
way again I'm completely presuming for
all of this discussion that naturalism
is correct
I cannot appeal to God or any
supernatural being to tell me what is
right in what is wrong even if I could
that runs into famous problems that was
they were pointed out by Plato and
others but for me I just have the
physical universe right the universe is
what exists that's what's real and in
that universe I don't see any moral
stances and immoral rules I see stuff
obeying the laws of physics now you may
have heard on certain corners of the
internet that we should be able to
derive moral rules from the universe the
idea of deriving aught from is what you
ought to do from what is actually
happening out there in the world and I'm
also sympathetic to this in some sense
right I mean my my best glib argument
that you should be able to derive odd
from is is is is all that is I just said
that I just believed the universe exists
right that's what is real and there's
nothing extra that is real other than
the universe so if we're going to talk
about thoughts about moral rules where
else would they come from from but from
the universe but
what actually is but sadly that doesn't
work there is another option which is to
say that you can't derive moral rules
from anything you can have moral rules
you can suggest them you can talk about
them you can debate them and you can try
to persuade others that they exist but
they're not being derived from something
deeper than that so it is literally I
know that you might have heard I had a
debate with Sam Harris about this Sam
doesn't like to put it always in the
terms of driving off from is but he has
put it that way sometimes and I debate
him just because it's a logical
impossibility to derive aught from his
there's deeper and more careful ways of
saying this but basically it is you know
as in computer science you have garbage
in garbage out in logic you have is in
is out if you make a bunch of premises
to your deductive argument that are all
about what does happen in the world you
could not have a conclusion that says
therefore this should happen in the
world there are a number of famous
attempts to do exactly that but either
they well but always they cheat let's
put it that way either they cheat by
using ambiguities in natural language to
make you think that we've gone from is
to ought or they smuggle in some extra
assumption which has ethical power an
extra assumption about what ought to be
and say well look this is so obvious
that clearly you accept it
that's what Sam Harris tries to do he
says you know certainly we shouldn't
think that the moral thing to do is to
maximize misery and unhappiness for
anyone well you know maybe we shouldn't
I I don't want to maximize misery for
everyone but that is an assumption that
is not something you derive from what is
out there in the world so I just want
him to state that that is an assumption
because then we can debate whether
that's the right assumption to make the
thing I disagree with is the idea that
it's not an assumption at all so I don't
think that you can get more rules just
by being out there looking at the world
the world doesn't have moral judgments
the world doesn't care what you do right
there will just obeys the laws of
physics if I give you the wave function
of the universe it involves overtime
according to the Schrodinger equation or
whatever future physics we someday have
there's no judgments there the
wavefunction the universe doesn't say oh
that was a mistake
to have evolved in that way that was an
ethically bad practice that you just
indulged in it just goes on uncaring
unfeeling we human beings as a part of
the world once we describe the world at
a higher level of the human world the
manifest image of the world where there
are people in it and those people think
and reflect and act we people judge the
world we attach moral meanings to
certain actions or certain things going
on out there in the world but they're
not inherent in the world itself
now there's clearly a lot of other ways
to be a moral realist even if you don't
derive aught from his and some literal
sense there's different ways of
justifying the idea that in addition to
the physical reality of the world there
are once and for all objectively true
moral standards I'm not going to go
through all the different ways to do
that and sort of argue against all of
them I'm just going to put forward the
idea that I don't think any of them work
despite the fact that this puts me in
the minority of working philosophers
we're much more educated about this
there's also a healthy minority that
agree with me about this I do think that
a motivation for searching for moral
realist justifications meta ethics often
comes from the idea that we like
certainty right I mean this goes back to
Descartes and many other people goes way
back before that the idea that we want
absolutely once and for all
certain groundings for our belief
Descartes was interested in our belief
in the physical world what we would now
think of as empirical questions are we
sure we're not being fooled by some
malevolent demon but it's very common
that you really just want to be able to
say not that you not simply that you
think that was wrong what you just did
but that it is objectively wrong it's
the same
of impulse that people have about
aesthetics that not only is this song
good in the sense that I like it or I
enjoy it or other people enjoy it but it
is objectively good there's a sense in
which it is simply better once and for
all and you can't argue against it so I
don't believe either one of those
stances certainly again if you compare
it to how we think about science how we
think about empirical questions about
the world if you make a statement like
the universe is expanding that's when we
can judge by going out there and looking
but crucially it could have been
different right we can imagine a
universe which was not expanding we can
imagine universe that is expanding we
can imagine one that's contracting we
can imagine one that's static so we have
many different possible universes and
then we go out and do observations
collect data to decide which of those
universes we live in that's just a
completely different procedure than we
have for morality very few moral
realists think oh I can imagine many
different systems of ethics and morality
and I'm gonna go out and do experiments
and decide which one is true that's
generally not how it works so I think
that we need to be comfortable to get
ourselves happy with the idea that
morality may be something that's
important to us but it's constructed
it's constructed by human beings just
like bridges are very important for
human beings and they're constructed by
human beings as well or the game of
basketball is constructed by human
beings
once you've constructed it it's there
but it's not inherent in the universe
itself so at this point of view which
again I'm not gonna do justice to all
the details of but you can find it
online this is goes by the name of guess
what moral constructivism moral
constructivism is just the idea that
what you and I take to be ethical
principles are made up by human beings
not made up necessarily arbitrarily
there might be good reasons to make up
some rather than others but ultimately
they come from within us as judgments
not from out there in the world or
objective principles of reasoning or law
or anything like that it's important
here to distinguish between moral
constructivism and moral relativism
they're closely related but different
they're both anti-realist versions of
morality but a relativist would say you
have some sort of community you have a
society in that society comes up with
moral standards and then what is right
and wrong is judged only relative to
what that society believes and it's sort
of a quietest view of morality in the
sense that if you're not a member of
that society then you don't get to have
an opinion right you don't get to judge
if you think that something is
personally repulsive but it's going on
and that society over there and they
think it's okay then you don't have the
right to say anything whereas a
constructivist doesn't say that a
constructivist simply admits the reality
that human beings are the ones who
construct moral rules but once we've
constructed them constructivism lets you
be judgey of other people it's not a
quietest point of view at all if I have
my moral rules and I've come up with
them for what I think are good reasons I
can apply them and I will and do apply
them elsewhere and I can use that as a
justification for acting in the world
for making things better even if other
people disagree with me now what I want
to emphasize here is that this picture
of morality given by constructivism can
sound a little wishy-washy can sound
like well it's not strong enough for me
if I if I've still bought into this
picture where I want absolute
metaphysical certitude for my moral
impulse for my moral rules in some sense
then the idea that it's just made up by
people might not sound robust enough
however I would like to point out that
it is nothing more or less than what
actually happens in the world we
actually do come up with our moral
theories in this particular way I think
that there's this slightly not perfectly
articulated fantasy that more realists
have that says that you know if I could
just find the objective moral rules then
when I came into disagreement with
somebody else in the world we could sit
down over coffee and I could
convince them that they were wrong
because I'm objectively right and
they're therefore objectively wrong so I
don't think that's actually ever what
does happen right I mean you typically
would not succeed sometimes maybe you
would good for you but I could certainly
imagine situations in which you would
not succeed in using the pure force of
reason to convince someone that they
should obey your objectively true moral
guidelines
whereas moral constructivism says yes I
come up with some moral rules that I
think are the right ones someone else
has come up with some moral rules that
they think are the right ones and we can
talk about who's right and who's wrong
which ones should be enshrined in rules
and legislation and laws and things like
that and sometimes we might just
disagree in a profound way and not be
able to overcome that disagreement guess
what this is what really happens in the
world moral constructivism is just about
bringing the way that we theorize about
ethics into line with the reality of how
we practice ethics in the world now
having said all that I talked a little
bit about these ideas in the big picture
in my last book and it's really focusing
there on these meta ethical questions
and I argue against moral realism and in
favor of constructivism but then you
want to go from that meta ethical stance
morals are things that we construct to
an ethical stance okay so what are the
morals that we should construct and in
the book I more or less punted on that
because it wasn't the point I didn't
want to say okay here are the rules we
should use I made some vague gestures in
that direction but that was not what I
was trying to do what I was trying to do
was to set up the idea that we can live
in a way that is both you know moral and
intellectually fulfilling in a
naturalistic universe so it still leaves
us the job of coming up with the right
moral rules so how do we do that and you
know there's a long complicated process
obviously there's work being done here I
think that there's two crucial
components about how we should go about
constructing our more
rules are ethical guidelines number one
we reflect on what our inner moral
impulses are right we human beings are
not blank slates we are not devoid of
moral judgment until we read you know
our first philosophy books we have
feelings about what is right and what is
wrong so reflecting on those feelings
means accepting and recognizing the fact
that sometimes our moral intuitions if
you like are not coherent are not
compatible with each other this is part
of the job of moral philosophy to take
our sort of inchoate rambling moral
intuitions and systematically turn them
into something that is logically clear
that says very definite things that do
not contradict each other this is the
kind of thing that we try to do using
ideas like a trolley problem thought
experiment right the famous trolley
problem you have a trolley headed to
kill somebody sorry a trolley headed to
kill let's say five people and there's a
switch that would move over the trolley
onto a different track where only one
person would die if you're a day
ontology sthoo says you don't want to
take an action that would bring harm to
anyone then you do not flip the switch
because that's a rule then you're not
allowed to do it it's not your action
that is literally hurting someone
whereas if you're utilitarian that says
clearly we should have the smallest
number of people dying then you would
flip the switch no problem and there's
no right or wrong answer these are two
different impulses that we
simultaneously have and the job of moral
philosophy is to sort of reconcile them
somehow and a moral constructivist would
say there might not be a right or wrong
reconciliation once and for all there's
no objective standard but this is the
task we have before us and the other
thing we need to do is to communicate
the first thing to do is reflect on our
inner impulses the second thing we need
to do is to talk to other people ask
them what their impulses are ask them
what their theory of morality is again
there's no guarantee that if we do sit
down over coffee and communicate with
each other and share our moral
intuitions and try to reason together to
come up with a mutually agreeable moral
system that we will succeed
there could be fundamentally reconcile
differences that we never get over so we
figure out some political way of dealing
with that we have valued diversity and
pluralism in a liberal democratic
society for example so we have to figure
out a way to get around that but it's
crucial along the way to actually ask
people what they care about what they
think is right and wrong not simply to
assume that we can logic our way into
coming up with the objectively right
answers and I think at the end of the
day I'm a little skeptical and this is
this is a very very tentative position
on my part so don't take me too much at
face value or too seriously I'm
tentatively thinking that there isn't a
simple maxim that sums up the right way
that I believe we should be moral some I
don't believe that there's anything
quite as easy as the categorical
imperative or the greatest good for the
greatest number that will ever work I
think that we human beings start out as
sort of a jangly bag full of moral
intuitions values if you want to call
them impulses that we have and some of
these come from biology and evolution
some of them come from our upbringing
some of them come from society some of
them come from our cognitive careful
philosophically logical reflection on
what we should believe in what we do
believe and at the end of the day we're
gonna have you know a bunch of rules of
thumb for how to deal with different
situations and we might grow and get
better and not even get better than
maybe that's a little bit of a morally
realist language sneaking in to my
rhetoric here but we evolved let's just
put it that way we can change over time
in what we think should be that that the
balance between different values values
like you should be kind to each other
you should care about other people you
should make people happy you should not
insult them you should respect their
personal space and their liberty and so
forth
a whole bunch of values that you know we
can all talk about and judge which
should be different levels of importance
and different particular situation now
is that unsatisfying is that not quite
as pristine and clear as you would like
especially if you're used to the
kind of theories that we get in math or
logic or physics sure it is unsatisfying
if that were your standard but maybe
that should never have been the standard
maybe we should accept the idea that
morality is something that is always a
little bit in flux that we're aiming
toward it without there actually being
in it that we will ever achieve right
literally it's about the journey rather
than the destination and we can talk to
each other and we can surprise ourselves
right we can say oh yeah you know I used
to think that was the right thing to do
but upon reflection after talking to
people after growing in my personal
experience and learning things now I
realize that I think that that was wrong
and that's a perfectly good way to live
so with all those in mind let's think
about how to actually take that
philosophy of right and wrong and apply
it to some sticky situations that we
actually run across in the real world
the first test case I wanted to talk
about is the notion of vegetarianism is
it okay to eat animals the ethics of
being a meat-eater I do think that this
is a topic where I'm a meat-eater I'm an
omnivore if you want to put it that way
but I think that most amenable are
unreflective about their hum neveress
nasai think that they grew up that way
they figure that's fine this is life and
that's how it is I do wish that most
people who ate meat gave more thought to
the ethics of it to whether it was right
and wrong of course this is part of the
motivation I had for moving naturalism
forward that I don't think that natural
ists or people in general give nearly
enough brain power for thought to the
moral and ethical values that they live
by and so I respect vegetarians who
become vegetarians for ethical reasons I
think you know that makes sense to me
why you would do that even if I don't
end up being an agreement with it at the
end of the day so what are the arguments
for not eating meat for becoming a
vegetarian I think you know there's two
broad classes although again there's
many little sub arguments here not going
to go into all the details one broad
class of arguments in favor of
vegetarianism comes down to the
environment too
more or less practical issues centered
on the practice of agriculture in our
actual world I think it is a true
statement and a very real concern that
modern agricultural practices are very
often harmful to the environment we
cultivate huge herds of cattle and pigs
and chickens and sheep and lamb and
goats and this stresses nature in ways
that are very clear these various forms
of livestock create methane which is a
greenhouse gas which leads to global
warming and also the creation of farms
often involves deforestation right
tearing down or burning down trees and
hurting the environment that way and I
think that these worries are perfectly
good worries I completely agree with
these arguments but I think that the
conclusion that these arguments is we
should change the agricultural practices
we should disincentivize harming the
environment I don't think that these are
arguments for becoming a vegetarian I
think that you know this is an example
where believe it or not I agree with
Dick Cheney our former vice president in
the philosophy of this Dick Cheney was
once asked about conservation of energy
not conservation of energy in the
physics sense but conserving energy in
the sense of not running the heater or
the air conditioner in your house or
driving too much and things like that
and he said you know as far as he was
concerned that was a matter of personal
virtue not a matter of public policy and
I think that's right I think that you
know whether or not you let the house be
a little bit cooler than is comfortable
and wear a sweater to make up for that
that is a matter of personal virtue I
think of the collective behavior of many
many people doing that well you know
what it's not that many people doing it
doesn't really make that much of an
impact on the world where I disagree
with Dick Cheney is that there I believe
there should be public policies that do
create a penalty for hurting the
environment so if you wanted to argue
for legislation to charge agribusinesses
money when they do things that harm the
environment because they're in some
sense poisoning the public Commons in a
very real way that I could very much
get behind but I don't think that you or
me or any set of individual people
choosing not to eat meat has a big
impact on that so that's a way in which
I would disagree with someone like Conte
right who says you should act in the way
that if everyone did it that would be
the right way to act I think that if not
everyone is doing it then it doesn't
really matter you know if it's if it's
not otherwise ethically bad the question
is you know how do we affect important
relevant effective social change it's
not by individual virtue it's by
legislation or you know sharp strong
demonstrations or something like that
ways to manifest the public well there's
various ways to get things done me not
eating hamburgers I don't think is
really doing it so the other sets of
arguments which I think are more
relevant for the current discussion are
the more purely ethical ones about
eating meat the idea that roughly again
roughly speaking because there's many
variations on this theme but we assign
where we might imagine assigning an
objective value to life whether it's
human life or animal life or whatever
and we might draw the line as to where
life is there is not important some
people would count plants what about
insects what about viruses or something
like that okay but there's some group of
living beings maybe just animals maybe
conscious creatures in some sense that
deserve do not have their lives ended
right
another thing that's true I'm saying
that is a potentially relevant
interesting moral claim in that case
killing whether it's human beings or
animals is simply wrong one way putting
this is why would you think it's okay to
kill cows and pigs and then eat them but
not kill cats and dogs and horses and
other animals that we choose for pets so
this is where you know the rubber hits
the road in terms of thinking through
our ethical rules that we're going to
construct as good moral constructivists
should we judge it to be wrong to kill
animals in and of itself after all we
judged to be wrong to kill humans and
you might have thought back in the day
before naturalism came along
well there is a reason why killing human
was bad because there's an objective
value to human life given by the special
place that humanity has in the world
either because of God or because of
something slightly vaguely more more
vaguely mystical in some way we don't
have that anymore so maybe the question
we should be asking is not why is it
okay to kill cows but why is it wrong to
kill humans right we don't have that
objective moral standard that we had
when we were religious we have to do
something different so as a moral
constructivist I would argue that it is
wrong to kill human beings but not
because it's some objectively absolutely
true reality of the moral world not
because of some quasi-mystical
attribution of an unbreakable right to
live on the part of human beings it's
wrong because we humans generally think
that killing each other is wrong we have
that moral impulse we have that value we
have that intuition that killing each
other is a bad thing if nothing else we
human beings generally don't want
ourselves to be killed right so if I
didn't want myself to be killed and I
was completely neutral on killing other
people the communication part of the way
in which we come up with our moral rules
would say you know I would go around
asking other people do they want to be
killed and most people would say no so
we would agree to come up with a rule
that said alright let's not kill each
other okay that's the kind of thing that
happens both in the real world and in
the theory of moral constructivism of
course I'm sure that you're thinking out
there some people will disagree there
are some people think that it is okay to
kill people John wick clearly thinks is
okay to kill people in certain
circumstances less fancifully there are
plenty of people who think the death
penalty is okay there's plenty of people
who think that there are just wars where
you can go out and kill the enemy so
there's different ways of dealing with
that right I mean there's you need to
sort of think a little bit more subtly
about when it is okay and it's not okay
to invent this rule about not killing
people and when someone is just a
sociopath someone just wants to kill
people we lock them up we put them in
prison at least once they have killed
someone
they have done some violent act that's
how mature societies deal with this
problem we've invented a rule and those
who stubbornly insist on violating it
are punished in some way that is again
both what we do in the real world and I
think what we should admit is what we're
doing it's not a matter of some
objectively real rule out there we
construct the rule and then we enforce
it so if that's the case if the reason
why we don't like killing people is
because we don't want to kill nor do we
want to be killed what do we start
thinking about animals and I think that
personally my feeling is that animals
are different now it's always tricky to
directly draw the line between what's an
animal and what's a human how are we
different from each other okay if you
listen to my podcast with Adam
Rutherford you know how subtle that
distinction can get but I think that
there is nevertheless a distinction
worth drawing obviously human beings
have eaten animals throughout history
animals eat each other
nature is red in tooth and claw that's
not an argument that it's okay to kill
animals or that it should be okay or we
should construct rules that says it's
okay it's just a preemption of the idea
that not killing animals is somehow
natural right the natural state is that
everyone kills everyone else or they
don't care because you know they're not
omnivorous right most animals actually
don't kill other animals but it's not
because they mind it it's not because
they invented a law or moral structure
against it just because they're not
interested they don't get any benefit
from it where animals do benefit from
killing any other animals that's
generally what they do in human history
so we are faced we need to come
face-to-face with this issue that we are
inventing the rules what rules should we
invent there's a couple of things that
matter to me here when it comes to how
animals are different and they base it
basically comes down to the
communicative part of how we invent how
we construct our moral rules and a
particular ability that human beings
have to conceptualize the future in
certain ways
parenthetically I should say of course
any time we try to draw a line between
humans and animals we might imagine
humans that are that are you know
injured or handicapped or disabled or or
have genetic defects or something like
that where individual human beings might
not fit into this categorization that we
have but I think it's perfectly sensible
to say that we're we're choosing to draw
the lines is around the human species
compared to other species in the world
so I think that's just a footnote that
we're not gonna get into in any detail
what I'm trying to do is ask what is the
distinction between animals non-human
animals as a set and human animals and
again another parentheses here other
people might disagree and that's okay
and we can talk about that that's cool
we should do that I have friends who
will not eat animals or creatures with
certain advanced nervous systems right
there's a famous rule that you shouldn't
eat things with a face okay so I'm
drawing it between human beings and
elsewhere I'm trying to explain why and
again number one there's the
communication issue and number two the
future issue so let me explain what I
mean by that the communication issue
what I mean is that we can't sit down
with animals and discuss moral laws
right we the part of the inventing our
morally constructed sorry are
constructed morals is that we talk to
each other and ask what each other want
and we do this in highly abstract ways
you know there's some ways in which we
can imagine talking communicating with
animals that's absolutely true
but there's also unmistakeably a level
of abstraction that we human beings can
reach that the animals can't we can draw
up contract right and it's actually I'm
realizing literally as I'm saying this
that the boundary between these two
points I'm trying to make is a very
fuzzy one the one point about how we
communicate and the other about how
animals conceptualize the future the
point being that you can certainly see
that animals know about the future right
I mean they worry in certain
circumstances things are going wrong the
thing you know the example I have in
mind is that when my cat's Ariel and
Caliban think that we're going to take
them to the
that they get upset they run away and
hide right when we pull out the cat
carriers in a way that is obviously
antecedent to putting them in the cat
carriers and then getting in the car and
going to the vet they know what that
means they know that the cat carriers
indicate something bad is about to
happen and I think that you know cats
are not the single smartest other set of
animals out there so there's no question
that animals can conceptualize the
future in some way but what's important
to me is the idea of conceptualizing the
future in a hypothetical way in a purely
abstract way that gives us the ability
to draw up mutually agreed-upon rules
and contracts you can train an animal
there's no doubt but what you can't do
is say all right look you know if you do
this for me tomorrow then next year I
will do the following thing for you
that's the kind of thing that as far as
I know based on the science and the
neuroscience that I'm aware of I could
be wrong about this that other species
other than human beings are not capable
of so the cats might run and hide when
we pull out the cat carriers but when
Jennifer and I are just talking about oh
we need to take aerial and Caliban to
the vet next week Ariel and Caliban do
not react to that they don't know that
it's going to be this bad thing they
can't quite conceptualize that future
event right I think that's important
because I think that that that idea of
how we conceptualize the future is
really secretly at the heart of why I
think that killing people is wrong okay
and again I'm going this over and over
again all this is tentative and you know
maybe I'm wrong so let's keep thinking
about it together but the example that
comes to mind again from my quantum
mechanics book is quantum suicide you
may have heard of this thought
experiment max tegmark popularized it
although other people talked about it if
you believe in the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics so
you believe that when a macroscopic
system observes a microscopic system
that the universe branches into multiple
copies and there's different things
going on different measurement outcomes
happening in each of those multiple
copies then imagine the following
experiment that you basically do a
quantum
like a Geiger counter or a spin or
something like that and you hook up a
machine where if the measurement comes
out one way you will be instantly killed
instantly is very important because
you're not suffering you just cease to
exist right away as much as
technologically possible and on the
other branch of the wave function where
the other measurement outcome was
obtained you're still there nothing
happens to you okay the idea is that in
some sense an intake mark himself
doesn't say this but other people have
said this you shouldn't mind being put
through this thought experiment roughly
speaking because there's now two
branches of the wavefunction where there
was only one in one branch you're alive
you have nothing to worry about in that
one and the other branch you don't exist
you're dead again we're presuming
naturalism there's no life after death
or anything like that so why should you
mind you there's nothing there to be
minding there's no you there to be upset
that you got killed okay so we're
putting aside issues that you know you
maybe you have friends and they will be
upset we're imagining an isolated loner
kind of person okay so I don't think
that this logic works as I explained in
the book something deeply hidden I say
look imagine a classical universe in
which there was a machine that could
kill you instantly so forget about
branches of the wavefunction just
imagine that Newton was right and there
was only one thing that ever happened in
the world but there was a machine that
could kill you instantly you wouldn't
know that you were dying right you would
be dead instantly you wouldn't suffer
and then after it happened you're no
longer there to be upset should you mind
if such a machine kills you well my
argument is I should be upset at the
prospect of such a machine killing me
because I want to live on right so the
reason why that would be bad is not
because I would be upset after I was
dead it's because I'm upset now at the
prospect of it happening because right
now I'm imagining all sorts of possible
futures for myself and that set of
possibilities is abruptly terminated by
this crazy machine and I think the same
logic works for quantum mechanics and
many worlds I think that the prospect
that in some branches of the
wavefunction I won't exist can upset me
just as much as not existing at all in a
single classical universe
would be bad and if that's the reason
why we should be upset at killing it's
because the people now are alive don't
like the prospect of dying apart again
from the fact that their friends might
mind and so forth then I don't think
that animals think the same way as far
as I know it's that's my reading of the
literature I don't think that they have
that sort of future-oriented
hypothetical imagination that lets them
think about a universe in which they
don't exist right and it's this is crude
and you know subject to revision upon
future scientific advances but to me as
far as I can tell that is a crucial
difference between human beings and
animals and at one it's one that makes
me not attribute this right to continue
existing to animals in the same way that
my morally constructed rules attributed
to human beings now clearly there's a
lot of details here right there's a lot
of more specific ways we could go into
that maybe someday we'll discover the
animals do have this ability we just
didn't realize how we could talk to them
and then I would update my beliefs I
would change my beliefs about what we
can do and again you know it does affect
questions like you know is it okay to
murder pets other people's pets well I
think that what matters there is the
human attachment to them I think that
forget about you know cats and dogs
versus cows and horses I think that you
know if you live in a culture where cats
and dogs are not pets where they are a
livestock then I don't think that
there's anything morally wrong about
eating them go ahead you know I think
that the reason why in our culture in my
culture in my house eating cats and dogs
is bad is because I have cats and I'm
attached to them and that's an emotional
feeling that I as a human being have and
that matters to me that that is
considered in my moral calculations now
that says this is different than
suffering of course now I did this
thought experiment with an imaginary
machine that ends your life instantly
that's an imaginary machine right that's
not the real world in the real world
killing often does involve suffering and
I think that suffering is bad and
there's no doubt that in the real world
of farming animals often suffer and I
disagree with that I don't want them to
suffer I am in favor of the animals on
farms living as happily as a life as
they can up until the moment that they
are killed I think that the killing
again is sort of morally neutral because
the animals are not anticipating dying
at some point in the far future because
they overheard it but the the actual
suffering in the moment that animals
undergo I think should be minimized as
much as possible just as it should for
humans again the question is about how
to actually make that social change and
it should be about laws and you know
regulations that make happy I don't know
what you know what if there's a
technical term for the kind of farming
humane farming I suppose that respects
the existence on a moment-to-moment
basis of the animals which I do think
has some moral weight and again among
there's another complication that I
should mention because morality is much
harder and more complicated in physics
is we human beings might value the idea
of things living if not actual every
specific thing you can't be too hung up
on individual organisms living because
we all die eventually right you cannot
put absolute value on organisms animals
and so forth living forever because
that's not plausible
death is real and important and you must
face up to it but maybe and I think very
reasonably you might care about the fact
of life itself right the existence of
living beings maybe you even care about
variety and diversity within the space
of living beings this may be you think
that a diverse set of species in a
diverse ecosystem is an independent
value I can totally get on board with
that actually I think that is perfectly
sensible to be against allowing
endangered species to go extinct right
preserving a variety of habitats and
animal species in the world is something
that I think is a perfectly reasonable
Val
you four we humans to get behind again
as before I don't think it leads us to
vegetarianism I think that we can have
both the value of having a diverse
ecosystem and eating meat at the same
time having said all this let me say in
case it's not perfectly obvious again I
totally respect people who don't go
along with this kind of thinking I want
us I want there to be mutual respect
right I don't want to lecture
vegetarians I don't want vegetarians to
lecture me I don't want anyone to
lecture anyone else in a sort of
hectoring way I'm happy to talk about it
in a rational way and maybe someone's
mind will even be changed you know
vegetarians and vegans especially have a
reputation of being lecturers of pushing
their values on other people I know that
that there are vegans and vegetarians
like that but look there are meat eaters
who are like that too I've had plenty of
examples of seeing meat eaters you know
tried to put their meat eating and shove
it in the face of vegans and vegetarians
we tend to you know be defensive about
our own personal values and that might
be something that actually happens but
it's not something we should be proud of
we should strive to do better which
brings us to the other example I promise
to talk about the intellectual dark web
and their engagement with political
correctness social justice warriors
things like that
I do recognize this is a subject some
people are tired of other people don't
want to hear about the it becomes
emotional and fraught and people take
sides and get very passionate about it
that's why I put at the end of this
podcast you're welcome to skip it if you
want to but personally I think it's
important that we talk about these
issues even if it can get heated
sometimes we have to be able to have
reasonable good faith dialogue about
things we disagree about even if the
underlying issues are by construction
ones that are very very personal very
very close to the heart of the people
who are talking about them and why would
I bring up the intellectual dark web in
a discussion that's opposed to eval more
reality and Metta ethics well for one
thing of course if we're talking about
social justice justice is important part
of ethics and morality for another I
think this is a good test case for
thinking about the relationship of
morality and rationality ethics and
reason these are two things morality and
reason that are not opposed to each
other right that we need to work in
concert in some way but there are
different things and so how exactly they
come together is an important issue when
we're thinking about how to be moral
what is the role of rationality when are
we using it when are we misusing it the
intellectual darkweb was coined as a
term by Eric Weinstein Eric is a the
managing partner at teal capital I
believe might not get exactly his job
title right I first heard his name a few
years ago when he was in the news at
least he was in The Guardian in the
United Kingdom the newspaper when there
were headlines saying that there was a
new theory of everything and Eric
Weinstein might be the next Albert
Einstein revolutionising physics many
people objected to this since Eric had
not actually written any physics papers
including about his new theory of
everything and it doesn't seem quite
sensible to dub someone the new Einstein
when they haven't even written a paper
yet
as far as I know the paper still hasn't
been written maybe it has I haven't kept
the track but it I'm pretty sure it is
not revolutionized physics I think I
would have known about that I would have
been informed about that thing but it's
just a term that Eric Coyne there's many
other people in the group jordan
peterson and sam harris ben shapiro
christina hoff sommers there's a sort of
loose knit collection of people nothing
official like I don't think there are
membership cards or anything like that
but there's this idea that there's a
group of people intellectuals who are
trying to reach the public through
non-traditional means not just getting
fancy professorships at Ivy League
universities publishing high-profile
books getting reviewed in the New York
Review and things like that I will
confess that it always rubs me a little
bit the wrong way when people foreground
the idea that what they're saying is
forbidden or contrarian or naughty
rather than what they're saying is
correct or right you know good ideas not
just forbidden ideas but okay you know
that's a stylistic choice that it won't
hold against them what is the idea of
the intellectual dark web other than
this Lucent group of people like how
would you define what group of people it
is besides their methodology for using
podcasts and videos not just books so
you can look on Reddit there's a reddit
subreddit dedicated to the IDW as you
might call them me intellectually web
and there it says the term intellectual
dark web refers to the growing community
of those interested in space for free
dialogue held in good faith the
community exists outside of any
governing body and has no biases to
adhere to it's a collection of people
willing to open rational dialogue
spending a variety of issues from
politics to philosophy so I think this
is a very problematic definition in a
number of ways it's just it's number one
the statement that there are no biases
to adhere to sounds rather unrealistic
to me but again that's not what I'm
going to focus on right now more
importantly is that this is not a
correct definition it's obviously not an
accurate definition if you want to
define what is holding together this
particular group of people and it's
inaccurate in at least two ways first
the idea that this particular group of
people is dedicated to open free dialog
is not at all borne out by the evidence
the most celebrated current member of
the intellectual dark web would
certainly be Jordan Peterson he's
accrued a good amount of celebrity in
the last couple of years and he
infamously threatens to sue people who
insult him by calling him a misogynist
for example he is called for university
departments that he disagrees with to be
shut down at one point he was planning a
web site that would keep track of
college courses containing what he
labeled postmodern content so that
students could avoid them if they didn't
want to be exposed to such ideas just a
couple weeks ago as I'm recording this
Peterson met with Viktor Orban who is
the president of Hungary if you're not
up on modern Hungarian politics or bond
is part of the populist wave that is
sweeping the world at least a mini wave
and he is let's to say not a friend of
free speech let's put it that way among
other things he's cracked down on
Hungarian ideas that he doesn't agree
with in many ways so much so the Central
European University which is located in
Budapest has fled it's moving to Vienna
in Austria because of the crackdown by
or Bonn Peterson seemed to have a
collegial meeting with or bon in which
they bonded over their mutual distaste
for political correctness so these are
not the actions of someone who's truly
dedicated to the ideals of free speech
members of the IDW are also not
uniformly pro-science Peterson and
Shapiro are have expressed sympathy for
climate skepticism there they don't
really think that the earth is warming
and Shapero at least I don't
I haven't dug up everyone's bio here but
I know that Ben Shapiro has been
sympathetic to intelligent design as
opposed to ordinary Darwinian evolution
so it's not obviously a priya pro
science group of people however okay I'm
just mentioning these because I think
they're important issues but what I want
to get at for this particular discussion
is the reddit description of what the
IDW is is only about methodology it does
not mention the substantive beliefs that
these people have the that it just says
we're open to free discourse rational
you know open-minded good-faith
discussions but you know about what and
what are the positions that they're
advocating in these good faith
discussions the members of the IDW seem
to be very insistent that they are not
politically homogeneous that they have a
diversity of viewpoints within their
groups there are conservatives there are
liberals what-have-you
they just want to advocate for free
speech but the reality is that they
actually do agree on some substantive
issues I think that a lot of people who
really are dedicated to the traditional
left-right dichotomy have tried to
shoehorn the IDW into conservativism or
even a gate
way to the alt-right I think that's kind
of a waste of time like I'm not that
interested in who is a gateway to what
if you disagree with somebody then
disagree with what they actually say
don't disagree with them because they
might lead someone to dis you follow
someone even more extreme right if
someone says true things and then for
whatever reason that leads to more
extremism down the road the things
they're saying are still true so my the
extent which I care about what the IDW
says is what they are actually saying
not where they might lead and I agree
that it's not really easy to put them on
a conservative liberal spectrum fully
right because there is a diversity of
opinions but again they agree about some
things the things they disagree about
are things like you know abortion rights
or health care or climate change okay so
there they are literally on the on the
filling the spectrum of political ideas
what they agree about well let's look at
the New York Times there's this famous
article by Barry Weiss that introduced
the IDW to the world where she mentioned
certain things they agree about
including there are fundamental
biological differences between men and
women and identity politics is a toxic
ideology that is tearing American
society apart and probably even if he
hasn't say it quite they're in that
paragraph they would include the idea
that there could be racial differences
in IQ that separates let's say blacks
from whites or Asians these are the
kinds of ideas that the IDW once out
there in the public sphere being talked
about okay so not including that the
fact that they don't want to mention
that in certain definitions of who they
are is another sort of red flag in my
mind I think that you know you should be
candid about the beliefs that you have
and want to spread there are certain
ideas you will not find being
promulgated in IDW discussions you will
not find a good faith dialogue saying
well maybe we should all become
intersectional feminists or maybe we
should support Sharia law courts here in
the United States what they agree on you
know there's there are cultural debates
here in the United States I will include
Canada because Jordan Peterson is
Canadian I it might very well include
they're places in the world but I
personally am just not familiar enough
with what the cultural divides are in
those places to opine about that here in
the u.s. we have certain cultural
disagreements okay there is the idea on
the part of the IDW that one side of
those ongoing cultural debates is being
repressive is being closed-minded
to the discussion of ideas is shutting
down debate and the side that they're
accusing of doing that is the
progressive social justice side so while
they may disagree on abortion or
healthcare they agree that there is a
threat to free speech and open dialogue
coming from the left that is why it is
sort of natural for some people to dub
them conservative even if though they
themselves wouldn't like that okay so
that's fine you know intellectually it's
fine to disagree with leftists on
certain things they might be right right
it's a little worrisome they don't want
to be candid about that a substantive
set of believes but it's certainly okay
to have substantives opinions but let's
think about what these substantive
opinions are actually about what they're
actually saying you know for one thing
they're not that naughty right the idea
there are fundamental biological
differences between men and women you
would have to work really really hard to
find people who disagreed with that
statement you know there are
implications of that statement that
people might disagree with but they're
not putting those implications front and
center they're not admitting to those
they won't have this incredibly banal
statement about there are biological
differences between men and women which
is not really very controversial in in
most quarters but if you think about
what these statements are the existence
of these differences and then the
implications that they tease out from
them between men and women different
races people who might qualify as
transgendered or lesbian gay queer those
kinds of people if you think about what
all these opinions are saying these are
not cutting-edge scientific discoveries
right the idea that there are
differences between men and women
these are Archie Bunker opinions these
are opinions that your racist uncle of
Thanksgiving would have no trouble
endorsing right these are just sort of
standard
standard-issue conservative opinions
about the natural differences between
different groups of people that doesn't
mean they're wrong that doesn't mean
they're incorrect just because these
opinions have been around for thousands
of years
okay they could still be right even
though they've been around for thousands
of years that often happens but the fact
that they might be cast as controversial
in this context despite the fact that
many people do hold them suggest we
should think about them carefully right
suggests that we should say well not
only what is the evidence for or against
this opinion but why is it that certain
people hold these opinions why is that
other that other people have become
suspicious of these opinions what is the
history of this and that's because when
we're trying to think about being
rational we're getting into the
relationship between rationality and
morality we have to admit that we have
opinions we have histories we have
pre-existing ideas in our head I like to
think about being rational and making
choices about what propositions to
believe in as a Bayesian okay which is a
fancy way of saying you say that for all
the propositions about the world you
could imagine you assign some
probability that they are true and if
you do that before you go out there and
look at the world you call these your
prior probabilities and of course you
never do that before you go out there
and look in the world you haven't
assigned any priors at all all of us
look at the world before we ever hear
about Bayesian reasoning so really what
we're thinking about is before you make
extra observations of the world
you tried to explicitly state what your
beliefs about the world are you have
background information about your
experience in life about how you grew up
about what you've learned and in that
listing of your priors you better keep
track of the fact that you have biases
we're all bundles of biases right if
neuroscience and psychology have taught
us anything we are not perfect reasoning
machines we can strive to be rational we
can aspire to get there to be to have
our cognitive capacities have a stronger
influence over how we live our lives and
make choices and assign credence is to
propositions but in the real world
there's all sorts of ways in which we
fall
of being perfectly rational not only do
we have biases that affect our beliefs
but also in what we pay attention to in
the world what we care about what we
value and it's not that we should strive
to get rid of our biases entirely we
move toward that but we'll never get
there okay we will never not have biases
that's just not psychologically or neuro
scientifically possible if you read
Daniel Kahneman's book Thinking Fast and
Slow it's a it's a good framework for
thinking about these things system two
is our rational cognitive capacities
system one in his classification is all
of our underlying heuristics and
shortcuts and intuitive ways of thinking
about the world and system one is the
boss really like system two thinks it's
it's in charge but it's analogized to
you know a tiny little person riding an
elephant you know the tiny little person
thinks they're in charge but the
elephant is doing all the work here and
that's our heuristics our biases we're
not going to get rid of them what we can
do is work to be aware of them to take
them into consideration and I think
that's the the primary message I want to
get at here in this particular
discussion you know as I started to save
me but in finishing it I don't care that
much about the intellectual darkweb as
such I am using them as an example as a
test case for thinking about these
issues of social justice political
correctness and so forth none of this is
new when I was in college in the 1980s
people were complaining about political
correctness it's like sex right every
new generation thinks it invented these
ideas but they've been around for a very
very very long time and so I think that
the what we want to get at here is how
we can best deploy rationality in a
world where we recognize we are not
perfectly rational we want to be moral
you want to be good people we want to
use the force of reason to help us
decide what is right and what is wrong
we can never forget that the force of
reason is imperfect in real actual human
beings so the intellectual dark web has
put the word intellectual into their
title I think that's good I'm in favor
of the word until
I'm not gonna begrudge them the ability
to name themselves whatever they want
it's important I mean but but that word
matters to me okay the word intellectual
has power and it should be taken
seriously intellectual doesn't mean
intelligent
it doesn't mean knowledgeable it doesn't
mean you're an academic or professor or
anything like that what it means to be
an intellectual is that you hold truth
as the highest value that you will work
towards being correct forgetting about
all of the other influences all the
other motivations all the other biases
you might have whatever truth you find
out you will stick up for regardless of
what other implications there are that
in my mind is really what it means to be
an intellectual even if those truths are
inconvenient uncomfortable and so forth
the opposite of an intellectual isn't a
stupid person a dumb person an
uneducated person the opposite of an
intellectual is aflac an ass-kisser a
toady
someone who makes up arguments to
support a pre-existing position
regardless of whether the evidence and
rationality actually leads them there to
a typical person who is not an
intellectual might be an apologist for
power for money for influence people who
are deploying their forces of persuasion
for some purpose other than finding the
truth telling people what they want to
hear is the opposite of being an
intellectual and included in the list of
people is of course yourself telling
yourself what you want to hear is not
what an intellectual should be doing and
we recognize this for example in science
in science we know that this striving
for getting at the truth is a constant
battle against our biases right that's
why we invent blind analyses
double-blind studies and so forth if you
heard my podcast with Kip Thorne you
know about the example of LIGO the
gravitational wave Observatory where
they were so afraid of giving in to the
temptation to find something even if it
wasn't there that they instituted the
system where they would inject fake
signals into the data
and not tell anybody there was like a
tiny group of people a committee within
the huge collaboration that was in
charge of injecting fake signals into
the data with the idea being that the
rest of the collaboration wouldn't know
whether that signal was faked or a real
discovery out there in the sky and their
job would be to take it seriously to
analyze it as if it were completely real
and then only at the end would it be
revealed up no we just faked you and the
idea is that you need to be on guard
against fooling yourself they wanted to
make sure that they would be able to
tell the difference between something
that really happened in something that
they were just patting themselves on the
back into thinking actually happened so
I want to extend this practice of
science the practice of knowing
perfectly well that we human beings are
not rational and have by a season like
to give in to them and therefore should
make extraordinary measures to safeguard
against doing that and I want to extend
it to morality and to rationality more
generally I think it's an important a
very important aspect of being a
rational person so the intellectual
darkweb if you think about what is these
substantive positions that they are
supporting we live in a world where
there are certain cultural fault lines
okay where certain groups have been
picked on historically certain other
groups have been dominant certain groups
have been oppressed certain groups have
been powerful and when it comes to these
cultural fault lines the IDW inevitably
ends up supporting the group which here
in the US or North America has been
historically dominant the powerful the
ruling group they are acting as
apologists for the established order of
things they want to say that the unequal
representation for example or at least
they want to let's say let's be try to
be more fair they want to argue for the
possibility that we should at least
consider that things like the unequal
representation of blacks and whites men
and women gays and straights and so
forth in various positions of power and
influence and wealth in the United
States is not a result of bias or
discrimination it's just a reflection of
the underlying natural
of things an unbiased playing out to
people's talents and inclinations that
is the general impression that they want
to either give or at least open to the
possibility of so if you think about
that claim if you think about the claim
that you know the difference between the
number of men and women in science or in
the United States Senate or in positions
of CEOs or on the Forbes 500 I don't
know what is the Forbes list 400 people
500 people billionaires the richest
people in the United States they're not
equal in you know men and women they
don't reflect the actual percentage of
men and women in the population or
blacks and whites etc so do you really
want to claim that this is just how
things should be it's not actually a
result of bias and discrimination that's
a very remarkable claim if you want to
state it quite that baldly we've clearly
had bias and discrimination in our
society for a very long time and it
hasn't gone away like in my mind it's
pretty clear that it's still out there
it's clear that we have made progress
you know you know there are people whose
ancestors not too long ago were slaves
here in the United States and there are
still effects of that but it's much more
recent than that when I was born in 1966
ok so not that long ago
within my lifetime women were not
allowed to apply to go to college at
places like Princeton Yale Georgetown
the University of Virginia okay a giant
public school the idea that women should
go to these places just wasn't
countenanced blacks were openly
discriminated against in countless ways
if you if you're familiar with the
history of how blacks were discriminated
against long after slavery was
officially eliminated you should read on
the history of redlining the idea of
drawing lines around certain areas of
certain cities where blacks were
concentrated and refusing to give
housing or housing loans or mortgages to
anyone who wanted to buy a house in
those areas this was an enormous Lee
influential policy not an official
policy written down in laws at least not
most places but it enormous Lee info
Rachele practice i should say that
prevented african-american families and
communities from accumulating wealth and
owning their own houses and lands for a
very long time it was officially
declared illegal in 1968 with the Fair
Housing Act but of course it kept on
going unofficially for a long time
there's a study in the 1980s where it
was much easier for poor white families
in Atlanta Georgia to get a mortgage
loan than for middle income or
high-income black families in Atlanta
and the results of this have been pretty
astonishing in 2009 is the most recent
year I could find numbers for the wealth
not the income which is sort of the
amount of money you make per year but
the wealth so the total of your assets
minus your debts the wealth of a median
white family in the United States is
over a hundred thousand dollars whereas
the wealth of a median black family is
under six thousand dollars there's an
enormous wealth gap between whites and
blacks in the United States so the idea
that in situations where you know very
recently there was official
discrimination and still today there the
lingering effects of discrimination and
bias in our society the idea that
somehow these effects don't play a huge
role in deciding who gets what job who's
promoted to what position who is paid
attention to who we listen to that seems
wildly unlikely to me we all know about
how recently gay marriage was finally
accepted here in the United States it
would be very very very strange indeed
to think that the attitudes that led to
these discriminator discriminatory
policies suddenly evaporated when the
policies themselves were finally
overturned presumably there were reasons
why we had these policies people had
beliefs that made these policies seem
like the right thing to do and even if
you change the law the beliefs don't
necessarily change even if they change
with some people they don't change with
others so to me as a good Bayesian
thinking about what my biases are and
what society's bias he's probably are
it's much more sensible to believe that
our society is suffused with
discriminatory ideas in ways both
obvious and
subtle so as rational people it should
be our job to accept that to face up to
that reality and to keep as much
vigilance as we can to make sure that
the effects of this discrimination and
the underlying attitudes that led to
this discrimination don't distort the
world we live in we want to live up to
the ideals of the Enlightenment people
who are you know famously people who are
the Enlightenment thinkers who found the
Enlightenment didn't themselves always
live up to the ideals of the
Enlightenment Thomas Jefferson owned
slaved slaves and raped one of his
slaves you know our actual people in the
past fall short of their own self
promulgated idea ideals but we can try
to do better right we can try to be as
close to those ideals as we can the
Enlightenment teaches us that we are all
created equal and we live in a world
where we are not all treated equal so
there's a mismatch and we should fight
against that the example of such a
mismatch that I'm most familiar with and
so I talked about it a lot is women in
science this is flared up as an issue
over the last year or two there's a
famous example where the physicist
Alessandro stru Mia gave a talk at a
conference that he got in hot water for
giving so this and it has become as you
might expect especially on the internet
a hot-button issue where people have
convinced themselves it's true me as a
martyr for the cause and and so forth if
I so screw Mia's point was roughly
speaking that women are underrepresented
in science because women on average
don't have as much talent or interest in
doing science as men do that was his
point now why was he even giving a talk
about that at a conference on women in
science you know he wasn't invited to
give the talk he invited himself he
asked to give that talk and when asked
what he was going to talk about he lied
he said he was going to talk about as
some details of bibliographical
statistics okay that was part of his
talk but that was not what his talk was
about what he meant by that was he
basically is ranking the value of
individual physicists by how many
citations they get by how often people
would cite their paper
in other in their own papers and you
know basically the the time it's almost
absurd like you couldn't if you wanted
to sort of embarrass the people who
actually believe that women are not
discriminated against you would come up
with a hero like alesandro's do mia it
turns out like in the middle of the talk
you begin to realize his real motivation
for giving this talk is that he applied
for a job and he didn't get it and a
woman got it and he became convinced
that the forces of political correctness
were flooding the market with
unqualified women at the expense of much
more qualified men and there are people
who believe this there are people who
believe it at different levels of
explicitness and I just want to you know
bring up the absurdity of this of this
idea you know there's not a lot of women
in physics ok the roughly speaking the
number of people who get PhDs who are
women is 10% that seems to be the number
that it's been for a few years now I I
was a host for a physics colloquium at
Cal Tech recently and I look at the
audience for the talk there are about 80
people in the audience and three of them
were women in on my floor of the
building in Caltech where the
theoretical physics group is is held
theoretical high energy physics group I
should say there's you know roughly
eight or ten faculty 10 or 12 postdocs
20 or 30 graduate students and for
several years in a row there were zero
women zero women among faculty postdocs
graduate students all in total in the
theoretical high energy group at Caltech
so whatever the reason for this is and
Caltech is not completely representative
and there are fluctuations because the
numbers are small ok but the idea that
the forces of political correctness are
flooding theoretical physics with
unqualified women is absurd on the face
of it because the women just aren't
there right it's just not working it's a
terrible way to flood the field if
that's what you're trying to do if you
think about it the idea that it's it's
really men who have a bad deal in
physics not women is exactly like global
warming denialism like climate denial is
so what do I mean by that so in both
cases in climate denialism
and in men are the real victims here
denialism in science there's a
phenomenon that is perfectly obvious in
climate the perfectly obvious phenomenon
is the average temperature of the earth
is increasing the earth is getting
warmer
okay in science it is that most
scientists are men they're not women
there's no word close to 50/50 and also
then there's a pretty straightforward
explanation for that phenomenon in the
case of the climate it's that we are
dumping greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere
okay carbon dioxide is shooting up and
you look at the curves it looks just
like the curve of temperature shooting
up for women in science women have been
discriminated against they weren't
allowed to go to college for many years
and those biases and those
discriminatory assumptions that lay in
the background haven't completely
evaporated but in addition to the
phenomenon and the obvious explanation
there are two other factors at work
number one there are complications in
the explanation okay that there is a
simple explanation in both cases but
there's also complicating factors life
is hard sometimes things are rarely very
simple for the atmosphere sure we're
putting carbon dioxide into it but
there's other things going on there's
ice sheets and permafrost and there's
the ocean versus the land and there's
all sorts of there's sun spots who knows
for women in science there are you know
there forces are trying to increase the
representation of women in science
there's women's own interests and being
a scientist or not being a scientist
there's having children there's a
million other complicating factors okay
and number two there is a political
motivation there is a reason to resist
the obvious explanation in the case of
climate there is both this
entrepreneurial you know capitalistic
motivation to say no I want to keep
burning fossil fuels because this makes
me rich and this is complicated for
other reasons if you remember my podcast
with Naomi Oreskes she explained how
libertarian politics and the fight
against the Soviet Union in the 1980s
really led to some people to resist the
scientific consensus on global warming
and there's complicate in there and
there's a political motivation for women
in science also there are men like
Alessandro's Rumia who don't want to
admit that maybe women are discriminated
against they they think of themselves as
perfectly unbiased right that's
perfectly fair in these things
so the complications if you look into it
if you dig in and do the science
carefully for global warming or for
women in science the complications of
the underlying explanation don't change
the underlying explanations when you do
it a little bit beyond the most naive it
turns out that sure there's a simple
explanation for global warming but
there's also more complicated things you
can do and the explanation still works
though the world is still getting warmer
it's still a bad thing we should still
stop putting greenhouse gases into the
environment for women in science yes
there's many complicating factors they
want to have kids family leave you know
maybe that very young ages they become
less interested in science but the
discrimination is still there and it is
keeping women out of science in very
very large numbers but if you're
ideologically motivated to deny the
reality you can leverage those
complications you can throw up a cloud
of disinformation right you can talk
about all sorts of other things going on
and this is a well-known technique in
propaganda right if there are if you
have an audience that is sympathetic to
a certain point of view even if that
point of view is not true you can give
them a reason for accepting that point
of view just by muddying the waters just
by saying all sorts of different things
and giving them sort of a license to say
well you know we don't really know this
is the kind of thing that Jordan
Peterson would say about climate change
right well we don't really know there's
a lot of complicated things we shouldn't
jump to conclusions and you see this
kind of thing at work in stru Mia's talk
right you can see the slides for his
talk online there's there's one that is
especially hilarious where he is
comparing the career a number of
citations to from women physicists and
men physicists and so you know he plots
the number of citations you have per
year five years after your PhD ten years
after your PhD 15 years etc and you can
see very clearly the men
keep going up and up and up and the
woman's sort of go up at a much lower
rate they seem to be accumulating fewer
citations over time now there's a hairy
argument to be made that total number of
citations is not an unmediated measure
of scientific quality it begs the
question of whether or not the women are
being discriminated against by getting
less citations but let's put that aside
the hilarious thing is that he
completely ignored the fact that women
leave science right he was comparing men
who stayed in physics for 50 years to
women who had done physics for five or
ten years and then left the field it is
completely unsurprising that their total
number of those citations over time are
very different because they spend a lot
of very different time writing papers
that's not not to say that the
underlying conclusion is not true but
the analysis is woefully hilariously
inadequate and it comes about because he
knew what answer he wanted to get and he
got it and then he stopped thinking
about it that's the kind of thing that
can happen when you're not an
intellectual when you're not devoted to
the truth when you have an answer you
want to get you sort of get there and
then you stop thinking anymore the
reality is that discrimination is real
against women against Blacks in a
million different ways there's
discrimination in physics as well as
elsewhere in the world that's what you
can test for and every test reveals you
know the same basic answer that bias
biases are real they exist this is why
concert musicians have developed a
system where if you want to audition for
the orchestra you do so behind a curtain
so the people who are listening to you
or listening to your music not looking
to see whether you are male or female
because the tests show that there was a
huge bias in favor of male musicians
there are obviously examples of
harassment within physics and harassment
is sort of the an extreme example of
something that happens all over the
place right professors commenting on
women's appearance
students and as well as other faculty
colleagues I personally see this all the
time I cannot possibly imagine how
someone could be in the physics
community
have their eyes even slightly open and
not see all the million ways in which
woman's worth is questioned as a
scientist it is it is just a constant
stream of very very subtle questioning
like hmm do you really belong here kinds
of things and you can say well you know
if you want to be a scientist you should
suck it up you should put up with all
those little people questioning your
worth
but it's unbalanced you know if people
need to suck it up that's fine but
there's no reason why women need to suck
it up more than men that's that's
exactly the example of discrimination
its death by a thousand cuts not
necessarily you know actively being
pushed out and it's not because you know
it's not a simple relationship between
math ability and whether you become a
physics professor there are more women
in mathematics than there are in
theoretical physics girls get better
grades in math classes than they do then
boys do okay girls don't do as well on
standardized tests of mathematics as
boys do past a certain age very early
age similar later on it becomes
different so the question is is doing
math in the real world more like getting
a grade in a class or more like taking a
multiple-choice test I think you could
make a case that it's more like getting
a grade in a class all of this influence
and all this questioning that women
really don't belong in this field it
starts very very young my niece you know
once we went to Christmas we gave my
niece and my nephew both Christmas
presents my niece who was like I don't
know eight years old ten years old at
the time she opens her Christmas
presents and it was a little erector set
to build an electric car you it's a tiny
little thing you built an electric car
you know there's little battery in it
and you made it go and she opens and she
looks at it she's very young and she
looks at us and says oh I think there
was a mistake this is for my brother and
we said no it's really it's really not
for your brother it's for you and you
could see her like struggling with this
idea like I don't get presents like this
right and it's not because she's
actively discriminated against not
because my brother and his family were
try
to steer her away from science or
engineering or anything like that just
was there there are suppositions about
what girls want versus what boys want
and the hilarious upshot of this story
is that you know half an hour later she
had built that car and it was zooming
around the floor and she was loving it
she had never been able to play with
something like this before we just sort
of start when children are born assuming
that they like certain things don't like
other things and you know for some girls
it wouldn't work you know some girls
would be completely not interested in
cars and that's perfectly okay but if we
don't give them the chance we'll never
know so what I'm doing here in this
discussion I know that I went on extra
long about that because it is very close
to my heart and I'm focusing on the
existence of the discrimination the
existence of these thousand mild ways
lays both mild and strong that women are
nudged out of science and the effect
that it has on them and I'm not just
having a discussion about what the
inherent abilities are given to us by
biology whether we are men or women that
is the subject that the people who don't
believe in discrimination tend to prefer
to focus on and the reason why I'm not
focusing on is because who cares I
really it's so there's this idea that if
I don't want there to be discrimination
I must be denying the reality of
biological differences that's not it
it's said I don't care about biological
differences it is certainly true to
anyone who has actually met both men and
women that the women who are good at
math and physics are better at it than
the average man at math and physics
right therefore knowing that someone is
male or female should have absolutely no
influence on how you judge them as a
mathematician or physicist or other
forms of scientist you should judge how
they actually are as an individual it
may be the case that there is a
difference between girls and boys
intrinsically and different kinds of
ability it may be that there's not any
actual intrinsic difference it's very
very hard to know that because of course
the moment you're born you start being
free
differently depending on whether you are
a boy or a girl but it doesn't matter
because discrimination is bad regardless
if there is a difference between men and
women and intrinsic ability and women
are also discriminated against just for
being women we should work to get rid of
that discrimination if there is not a
difference between men and women at
intrinsic ability and there is
discrimination we should also work to
get rid of that discrimination that is
what matters
the people who concentrate on the
possible existence of intrinsic
differences in ability between men and
women based on standardized tests these
are generally not people who have a
professional interest in genetics or
psychology or anything like that
sometimes they are but there's a lot of
people who are not in that camp who
never less seemed fascinated by this
particular topic the only reason they
are is because they are being apologists
for the current system they are being
apologists for the idea that there is no
evidence for discrimination because they
want to say I can map the existence of
intrinsic ability onto the number number
of Nobel Prize winners and the number of
faculty members etc but that's an
irrelevant argument if there's a
separate way of looking and asking is
there discrimination out there in the
world anyone who is working in the
sciences or who studies science knows
that there is discrimination out there
and that's bad and that's what matters
and of course there are similar things
to be said about race about sexual
identity and so forth there's a number
of ways in which discrimination is still
real we want to be better people but
we're not people yet we're not but we're
not perfect people who probably never
will be perfect people we need to keep
working on it and you know look
discrimination and things like that they
don't necessarily come out of evil or
bad impulses I've known the sweetest
people who would be horrified at the
idea that they were in any way sexist or
racist who never the last exhibited
ideas predilections right that would be
obviously by an outside observer labeled
as sexist or racist and those secret
attitudes those parts of you that you
don't
always bring up to the surface and
question can absolutely affect how you
go through your life but I don't think
it's evil or even necessarily amoral
miss calibration and this finally gets
us back to this issue of the interplay
between ethics and morals and
rationality and reason if you want to
follow the advice of the intellectual
dark web you should be rational Ryan you
should be reasonable ben shapiro likes
to say facts don't care about your
feelings and this is very very true but
we all have feelings whether you like it
or not we should admit that we have
feelings sometimes you got a dig deep to
get to the ultimate facts confronting
feelings that you might not want to
admit are there inside you there is this
temptation as I said to come to the
conclusion you like and then stop
rationality is often used for purposes
of rationalization of taking rationality
should be you start with the data and
you work for the conclusion
rationalization is you start with the
conclusion you like and then you go
backwards and construct a seemingly
rational justification for it we are all
subject to this I'm not trying to pick
on people who I disagree with
politically I'm subjected to this I have
racist and sexist parts of my upbringing
that are still there how in the world
could I not we live in a racist and
sexist society there's overwhelming
evidence for that I can try to be better
I don't want to be racist or sexist but
if I were to just simply say you know if
I were Stephen Colbert when his in his
character of The Colbert Report and say
you know I don't see race I think that
you're a young Asian woman right that's
a joke because it can't be true we
should admit that we are human beings
bundles of impulses and heuristics and
system one chattering away beneath the
surface and be open to the possibility
that that affects our behavior
rationality is instrumental it finds
conclusions from whatever inputs it gets
but we can ask ourselves even if we are
perfectly rational where do the inputs
come from where'd what facts about the
world do we choose to look at okay so if
I am concerned
that maybe women are getting unfair
advantages it's very easy for me to see
certain fellowships or opportunities for
women in particular that men don't have
I can see that hiring committees faculty
hiring committees go out of their way to
find female candidates and that is
bright and vivid to me and makes me mad
and makes me feel there's injustice in
the world and I can just not notice all
of the ways in which women are nudged
away from science throughout their
entire lives from when they're born
through elementary school through high
school through undergraduate through
graduate school and Beyond and so to me
I'm being rational when I say like look
this is very unfair that there's this
fellowship that only women can get or
there's this job that this woman got and
it's because of the garbage in garbage
out principle I didn't have I didn't
take into account all of the facts of
the real world but the facts I chose to
take into account I reasoned with in
some way so you can see a conservative
speaker invited to a college who is
being heckled or even being D platformed
not allowed to give a talk at that
college and you cannot see the reality
of racism or sexism or homophobia or
transphobia that affects the lives of
students in these situations so for in
my opinion people stifling speech in the
name of fighting racism is bad I am not
in favor of that I'm very much in favor
of a wide variety of speech about all
sorts of things even the worst people
should be able to talk if there's a
group on campus that wants to invite a
speaker I think that they should always
be allowed to invite that speaker no
matter how bad the person is and some
people disagree with me about this some
people think that certain people are
beyond the pale they should not be
allowed to be invited not just
campus-wide but even by any group on
campus so I disagree with them and I'm
happy to have that conversation with
them in my mind this problem of racist
speakers being invited to campus or not
being invited to campus is not anywhere
near as bad as the problem
of racism it's it's almost absurd to try
to balance the the effect of racism on
the lives of black people in the United
States versus the problem of this
particular speaker didn't get to give a
talk because they were considered to be
racist they're both problems but they're
not problems of equal magnitude in my
mind and I know that what some people
will say to that kind of argument is you
know I I can choose there's many bad
things going on out there in the world I
get the right to choose which bad things
I'm gonna focus on right you know I
can't solve all the problems of the
world some problems are more important
to me than others I think that's a true
statement
but there's a limit to how far that
reasoning goes when the problems we're
talking about are closely related the
idea I have in mind is if you go to a
restaurant and you order soup and it's
supposed to be hot and you get it cold
okay so this is a traditional setup for
complaining to your waiter you say
waiter my soup is cold it's supposed to
be hot now if the waiter were to say to
you how dare you worry about something
so trivial as cold soup when global
climate change is destroying our
environment l beat absurd response on
the part of your waiter right I mean
it's true climate change is a much
bigger problem than the temperature of
your soup but it's a problem from a
completely different area the the waiter
has no right to say like you should
spend exactly as much time complaining
about problems and proportional to how
bad they are that's not a good way to go
through life but if the waiter said how
dare you worry about something so
trivial as the temperature of your soup
when the kitchen is obviously on fire
and we're evacuating the restaurant in
that case the waiter is correct right
and that's because that particular issue
the kitchen being on fire is closely
related to the situation going on in the
restaurant right then so sure you can
say well I care about free speech not
about racism but when free speech and
racism intersect it makes sense to
balance the relative importance of these
different problems I think that fighting
racism is a much bigger problem than the
getting speakers on campus even if they
are both problems for many people in our
culture is
we don't want to admit it the
metaphorical kitchen is on fire the
restaurant is burning down they live a
life where there's just a huge number of
ways in which they are not treated
equally not because of who they are as a
person but because of what group they
belong to that doesn't mean that such
people are right about everything or
that they're you know view of the world
is intrinsically correct but it offers a
perspective that other people might not
have when you do not have to put up with
certain forms of discrimination it's
hard to put yourself into the mindset
into the world into the life of someone
who does I had this discussion with Paul
bloom on the podcast and Paul wrote a
interesting provocative book about being
against empathy and his argument was we
tend to empathize with people like
ourselves and by doing that empathy gets
in the way of being rational okay again
the this morality and rationality
intersection and he argued that you know
if we were simply rational then we could
be moral we could be better people
without trying to put ourselves in the
situations that other people are facing
without being empathetic I think there's
a huge mistake in that analysis because
clearly if we do restrict your empathy
to people like yourself then yes then I
agree with him then you can in fact be
irrational about your moral conclusions
because you're not taking into
consideration the perspectives of other
people but my solution to it is we need
more empathy not less we need to train
our empathy to really let us understand
where other people are coming from
especially when people have very very
different life situations than we do I'm
not a believer that someone with a
different life situation than me has
magical insight that I must sort of
instantly accept when they offer it but
I do as a you know enlightenment thinker
as someone who believes that all
knowledge is provisional and fallible
and subject to updating I realized that
they know something I don't
and I should be able to listen to them
and learn something that's the important
thing it's not accepting what black
people say about racism just because
they're black it's accepting that they
know something about racism that I don't
because they're black because they've
lived a different experience I should
try to listen to what they have to say
when I do my best to accept what they
have to say then I should reason by
myself than I should you know do the
best I can to reach a correct conclusion
but I have to be open to those
experiences to those voices to those
different ways of living in the world
and you know I even think there should
be empathy for privileged straight white
men I'm in favor of that the word
privilege has become very charged
obviously we talk about male privilege
about white privilege and so forth and
it rubs some people the wrong way and I
get it why it rubs people the wrong way
I also get why it's used and I think
it's a useful concept but if you are a
straight white man and you're accused of
having white privilege for example you
can instantly start thinking to yourself
well I'm not privileged my life was
tough I earned what I got right I mean
maybe you were poor maybe you were just
like not that socially adept when you
were young
maybe you faced a great tragedy your
parents died or something like that
there's a million ways in which your
individual life may be a struggle even
though you were labeled as having white
privilege or male privilege or something
like that but privilege doesn't mean
that you had an easy life that's that's
not what the word means in this
particular context what it means is that
there are obstacles that you don't face
simply because of your membership in
certain groups it doesn't mean you don't
face other obstacles but guess what
people who are black or gay or
transgender or whatever they can also
face the obstacles of being poor being
socially awkward having family tragedies
and what-have-you and they also can face
things like racism and misogyny and
transphobia which you don't have to if
you are a straight white person the
example that comes to mind since I
always conceptualize difficult problems
in terms of basketball analogies
recently the Toronto Raptors won the NBA
championship in a game in Oakland over
the Golden State Warriors
and Masai Ujiri who is the general
manager of the Toronto Raptors so he's
the guy who chooses which players to
trade for and to draft into sign so he's
basically the boss at the basketball
team
and when they won the game to finally
win the championship Game six he rushed
out of the court to join the celebration
and he was held back by a police officer
and the police officer originally
claimed that who Jiri actually had
punched him but then guess what of
course it's you know the NBA
championship and they just won and
there's a million cameras and videos
around there's no punching involved as
it was shown so the police officer then
said well he didn't have his credential
guess what he was carrying his
credential in his hand so Ujiri
was wearing a suit he was carrying his
credential in his hand he was the
general manager of the basketball team
that had just won the NBA title and when
he tried to join the celebration he was
stopped by a police officer now maybe
this would have happened were he white
but he wasn't white and it happened and
I think that by any objective way of
measuring the probabilities here the
chances that would have happened had he
been a white businessman looking general
manager are much lower it's an example
of privilege that there's a different
way of looking at people and individual
cases are always a little problematic to
lean on because you never know maybe in
this particular example the officer had
instructions that would have led him to
do the same thing for anyone of any race
or ethnicity I don't know that for sure
what you know is that there's an
accumulated effect of many many many
examples of things like that of how
people are treated differently because
of their skin color in the United States
so that's a real kind of privilege that
white people have it doesn't mean your
life was easy it means you had a
different life experience okay so where
are we let's bring this back to this
original question of how to be a good
person how to act morally in the world
and let me use an example from sam
harris and you know it sounds like i'm
picking on sam harris i don't mean to do
that I talk about Sam a lot because he's
worth
engaging with I think that he's his he's
more interesting as more interesting
things to say to me than some of his
intellectual dark web compatriots his
podcast for example was certainly a role
model for mine inspiration for thinking
that you could have long conversations
about intellectual topics and people
would be interested in and listening to
it that there's not a lot of evidence
for that in the world and he certainly
provided some so when I engage with him
it's because I think it's worth trying
to engage in constructive disagreement
so there was a time on his podcast I
think is with Jordan Peterson probably
was given the subject the subject was
pronouns being used by transgender
people you know a lot of transgender
people want to be referred to by very
specific pronouns that they care about
sometimes they will want to choose
pronouns from the existing English
language he/she so forth other times
they prefer made-up words because
they're in a different situation then
cisgender people would find themselves
and this is an ongoing controversy about
how we should deal with this so Sam put
forward his opinion that he thought that
people requesting to him that he used
certain pronouns to refer to them he was
not in favor of that because he thought
it is a positive imposition on asking
him to do something not just asking him
to not do something bad but asking to
him to do something actively good it
takes energy right and if we just
extrapolate you know there's an infinite
number of things that I could be asked
to do and that's not something he thinks
is quite fair so my attitude you know
towards this is you know yeah yeah it it
is asking you to do something positively
it would take energy making the world a
better place might very well require
effort require an exertion of energy
even on the part of people who have not
themselves made the world a worse place
okay I I think that's just a very
plausible thing the argument that there
could be an infinite number of things
you were asked to do is just kind of
silly right there's not an infinite
number of things you're asked to do
you're asked to do the things that makes
the world a better place that makes it
more
pher that lets people be treated how
they want to be treated people who are
not transgender typically have no
trouble at all getting referred to by
the pronouns they prefer this
automatically happens for them people
who are transgender have to work at it
and that is an imbalance between the
life experiences of those different
people in my mind and again maybe this
comes down to empathy transgender people
have to put up with a lot they are born
and grow up into this realization that
they don't conform to what the world
expects of them they're not what the
society around them once them and
believes them to be and they're
constantly reminded of that that is a
tough way to grow up right or even if
you find out about it later in life a
tough way to exist it can result in
bullying ostracism you can be ostracized
from your family or friends you can
become depressed sometimes at least a
suicide it's not an easy way and there's
a lot of courage associated with being
able to openly live that way
so if I learned that I can make
someone's someone like that someone like
that life easier simply by referring to
them using the words that they prefer to
be referred by that sounds to me like
the very least I can do there's not that
many ways in which I can clearly and
obviously make the world a happier
better place that is one of them so I
find it very easy to do that I mean not
easy to necessarily know what someone's
preferred pronouns are that's a sticky
social situation that we're still
working at but if someone tells me what
they are I will do everything I can to
try to use them and that can be tricky
too because again system one is in
charge here how we refer to people is
often unconscious and we have to sort of
consciously override and it can be work
I get that to me I think it's worth work
very well worth doing I think that a
huge part of being moral being a good
person in the version of morality that I
construct as a constructivist is
breaking out of our biases our
perspectives we should always start by
thinking you know I'm probably a little
bit biased right
that's the safest way to go through life
because then you're open through to how
that manifests and if you find actually
it's not really manifesting I'm behaving
in a very non biased way good for you to
me this is the Enlightenment at work
right
this is treating people with equal
dignity cosmopolitanism openness to new
experience being able to admit that our
beliefs our perspectives might not be
complete might not be right we can
always do better be aware of what our
biases are even the possibility of
biases that we haven't yet recognized do
everything we can to get rid of them and
I know what some people are thinking
here isn't there also a bias the other
way or couldn't there at least be a bias
couldn't there be a bias towards sort of
the righteousness of feeling that you
are oppressed and that gives you some
extra handle on virtue or something like
that yeah absolutely
100% I agree with the possibility of
that bias I think that we can all be
bias again it's a human thing it's not
doesn't belong to one group or another
we're not rational we're not perfectly
rational perfectly virtuous perfectly
moral we can all work to be better at it
but again I think that there's a sort of
comparison to be done if there are
groups that are historically oppressed
picked on not treated equally I'm gonna
be a little bit more sympathetic to them
you know fighting against this than the
people who are in the dominant group you
know they're I'm very sympathetic to
worries about free speech as I said I
think that we could do a much better job
those of us who believe that free speech
is important I think we could do a much
better job in acknowledging and
understanding and talking about the
reasons why certain people don't want to
be subjected to certain kinds of speech
if you simply don't understand that
motivation then you're not being
rational you're not being intellectual
you're not facing up to reality I try my
best to understand why certain people
don't want certain speech acts to happen
and to understand why that is and work
within it my current understanding just
like with vegetarianism is
that nevertheless despite the very real
harm that speech can do it's worth it it
can be you know put in certain regions
like you you needn't be forced to hear
certain kinds of speech you there should
be safe spaces where you can avoid
certain kinds of speech but there should
be other spaces where that speech is
available if that's what you want to go
to I do believe there are people who go
overboard in fighting for racial justice
or sexual justice or whatever and they
become so enthusiastic that they want to
shut down people who disagree with them
and I don't come to that conclusion I
disagree with those people that doesn't
make them my enemy if I reach a point
personally where people who go overboard
because they're fighting against racism
and sexism and discrimination I start
thinking of them as my enemies rather
than allies I disagree with then I'm
gonna have to rethink my own life
choices here I'm gonna have to take a
step back and think about where I am I
can be on the same side against racism
as someone whose tactics and strategies
I disagree with I have no trouble
believing that at all I did on Twitter
at one point try to promote the idea of
million social justice after John Stuart
Mill of course the famous philosopher
who gave the most eloquent defense of
free speech and the free-market of ideas
and he also gave a very very eloquent
defense of the rights of women now it
may be that his his wife Harriet Taylor
I don't know actually I don't know if
they got married I think they did get
married later in life but Harry Taylor
probably was responsible for a lot of
the ideas and even some of the writing
in the subjugation of women and some
other of Mills books but I like the idea
that things like freedom of speech the
free market of ideas the give-and-take
of dialog and discussion and openness
the realization that we're all fallible
and imperfect and biased and working to
get better all of that taking together
is a powerful force could be a powerful
force for social justice not just
against it that if we do it right if we
talk to each other in the right way if
we are open to listening to
they're people we're opening to
admitting that we're not perfect that we
come with a bundle of ideas beneath the
surface that we might not even be aware
of and we can always do work to improve
them and one of the ways to improve them
is to listen to other people listen to
people who we disagree with even if we
end up still disagreeing with them even
if we learn nothing doing a little bit
of listening I think that doing that in
good faith is actually a great force for
making the world better including
fighting against racism sexism other
forms of bias and discrimination I'm
hoping that in some broad but minors
sense the podcast pushes us in that
direction you know I don't want to
actually spend a lot of time on on
mindscape talking to out-and-out racists
but I do want to talk to people I
disagree with especially about
strategies for making the world a better
place all of this as I said very much at
the beginning of this overly long solo
podcast all this is very tentative in my
mind like these areas of being a good
person being moral having good ethics
these aren't things that anyone should
be all that certain about in their own
minds we can all learn and do better I'm
trying trying to do better hopefully
we're all trying to do better let's see
how well we do thanks for listening bye
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]